this is not Tech
poy neither is
this nope not this either fighting words
perhaps but I'm also hoping once I've
made my case that you'll understand why
I'm saying so and why me saying so is
not a value judgment on any of those
[Music]
artists Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain in this video I want to dive into
how we talk about artistic movements in
the PO world and why I think we missed a
pretty big shift roughly 10 years ago
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroar light toys spinballs and
Ultra for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- bus friend of the channel Becca
beonin thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission I have every faith that this is
going to be a controversial video a
couple years ago I uploaded a video
outlining why I believed Tech poy had
declined and eventually died out as an
artistic movement and people were pretty
upset with me for it so let me say right
from the jump here that the label we
place on a style of Po isn't a statement
on its difficulty value or worth lots of
stuff being done today is incredibly
difficult and advanced but that doesn't
mean that it's being created with the
same intention or cultural context as
Tech POI was more than a decade ago I
think it's helpful to keep track of
these sorts of artistic movements in the
PO world because they can tell us a lot
about how demographics shift over time
the way culture evolves and even what
are seen as the ESS entral values within
a community so with all that said let's
talk about tech POI and the movement
that I believe succeeded IT Tech PO is
an artistic movement within the PO and
flow Arts community that I believe
lasted roughly from 2005 to 2013 that
was dominated by three very key tenants
the first is the parameterization of poi
that is thinking of poy tricks as
consisting of a set of variables that
can be adjusted to produce a variety of
different results the second is a focus
on petrix based on roulette curves like
those traced out by a spirograph this
places the emphasis not on the immediate
movement or momentum of the poy but the
shapes that it traces out over time and
how those shapes can interrelate or be
combined and finally attempts to form
broad theories explaining the
relationships between a wide variety of
poy tricks and hopefully anticipate
tricks that had yet to be discovered to
my mind Tech POI as a movement began to
emerge with the publication of rev's
spherulous Manifesto which collected
together his thoughts on POI inversions
the movement then crystallized with the
creation of the tech POI group on
tribe.net in 2005 thus giving the
movement its name Techo wasn't simply a
new label for advanced POI work it was a
specific artistic movement that
represented a particular philosophy
toward POI that was a product of a
number of cultural and artistic Trends
contemporary poy had been floating
around as a somewhat nebulous and
decentralized phenomenon for more than a
decade because the only way you could
learn to spin at the time was either
from an in-person teacher or a DVD the
adoption of Po happened in very small
numbers and styles were very
personalized and regionally specific as
access to the internet became more
widespread and online forums a popular
way to create online communities of
like-minded people po Spinners from all
over the world began exchanging ideas
back and forth via forums like home of
poy spherical ISM and tribe because
these online forums weren't always
terribly userfriendly they tended to
attract people that were computer savvy
these were people with a great capacity
for abstract reasoning and logic these
po Spinners overwhelmingly young men
gravitated towards poy tricks that could
easily be visualized with the limited
Graphics capabilities of these online
forums tricks that could be presented
with simple charts were those most
likely to be understood and learned by
other people reading these posts and
just a few years earlier Nick woy had
radically changed the PO landscape by
popularizing flowers with his Milestone
video dervish Le yours flowers were a
perfect fit for this type of
visualization many of the seminal works
of the Techo movement including unit
circle Theory Vulcan Tech gospel and
nine square Theory were all attempts by
computer savvy young men to apply the
tools of combinatorics and logic to the
world of poi flowers in the process they
shared resources for discovering a wide
variety of Po flowers hybrids and tools
for transitioning between them the
introduction of YouTube became a
catalyst for this Movement by making it
possible for people performing these
complex tricks to share videos of
themselves performing them instead of
Simply charts demonstrating the Core
Concepts a popular format for these
videos was the tech blog Tech blogs
usually consisted of a performer
demonstrating a series of individual
tricks or concepts they wish to Showcase
rather than an explicit attempt at
performance with any form of narrative
few Tech po Spinners attempted to work
their tricks together into acts pieces
or performances the goal was to create
all-encompassing theories rather than
showcase their work in a format more
accessible to people outside the flow
Arts world and because Techo Focus so
completely on patterns it was ideally
suited to both fire and led two of the
most popular styles of spinning po at
the time but the drive to create ever
more complex patterns frequently led to
the creation of moves that were
completely indecipherable to anyone who
had only a passing familiarity with POI
or none at all to say nothing of
branches of poi theory that got ever
more abstract and divorced from
classical POI techniques quarter time
third order motions and toroids all
piled on complexity to create families
of tricks that were incredibly difficult
to perform cleanly and the widespread
adoption of both social media in the
form of Instagram and Tik Tok as well as
the wide availability of cheap but
highquality cameras and smartphones
opened up the floodgates to a variety of
other styles and approaches to the prop
the first hints of a departure from the
core tenants of Techo started coming
around in the early 2010s seral human a
Swiss pois spinner who' first made his
name with a widely encompassing Treatise
on Symmetry and poy patterns made a
radical shift in his style to jump start
contact po as a discret corner of the
poy World his videos Mana poy and
brainstorming became revolutionary
cornerstones of a new style of poi that
had little to do with traditional weaves
or flowers and Scottish poy spinner
Keith Marshall released a series of
videos reintroducing the POI world to a
variety of poi tosses and negative space
tricks heavily influenced by the
juggling world but truth be told I can
remember exactly when Tech po died
because I was there to watch it happen
and it took place over the summer of 200
13 thanks to two major events the first
was Keith Marshall coming to the United
States to tour the flow Festival circuit
he arrived ready to spread the gospel of
three poy and didn't just spin them but
juggled them he quickly won an enormous
amount of influence over the young Tech
Spinners on the festival circuit that
year who threw themselves passionately
into learning his techniques the second
was the European juggling Convention
held that summer in to France Not only
was this location relatively accessible
to International Flyers it was also
being held at one of the most
prestigious circus schools in Europe
this convention had an enormous impact
not just on the young po Spinners that
Keith was influencing but on the flow
Arts World in general flow artists from
all prop disciplines came away from the
event with a strong drive to integrate
circus training and performance
techniques into the flow arts and some
even sought assimilation into the
juggling and Circus World entirely there
was a word that I often heard people use
to describe the tricks and sequences
inspired by these techniques and one
that I think makes for a great label for
this artistic movement that word is
manipulation and just like Tech pooy
manipulation had several tenets at its
core the first and probably most
important was the integration of
juggling Concepts into poy from numbers
juggling to styles of catches and throws
balancing and contact manipulation
centers around essentially treating the
poy as one would a club the second is
virtuosic control over the PO momentum
manipulation requires the capacity to
make infinim small changes to the
movement and iner of different segments
of the poy to retain clean lines and
trajectories for throws rolls and
balances finally there is an
overwhelming emphasis on Clarity and
cleanliness of technique it's not enough
to come up with a dynamite combo of Po
moves the lines in presentation for
those moves must be Immaculate you'll
also note that I've started referring to
POI in this context not as po spinning
but just simply as POI and that's no
accident frequently manipulation doesn't
even involve the POI actually spinning
many of the moves used in manipulation
require none of the kinesthetic
techniques we'd associate with things
like weaves or even flowers there is now
an entirely new way to train the prop
that centers more on balance and control
over throws than plane control or adding
or removing pedals and this difference
in focus and philosophy has also
resulted in a huge change in culture and
demographics too for one thing while
Techo was dominated by computer savvy
young men manipulation has less of an
emphasis on mathematical reasoning or
theoretical constructs manipulation more
often simply borrows decades old Theory
from the juggling world and applies it
to petrix and because of the incredible
amount of physical Precision required by
most manipulation tricks people who
engage in it train physically in a much
more disciplined and consistent fashion
than those who were deeply invested in
the tech POI movement the mental
component in Tech POI was as important
if not more important than the physical
component you'd spend as much time
theorizing about New Tricks as you would
trying to figure out how to actually
perform them with manipulation on the
other hand hours spent training are the
primary focus manipulation also favors
an act that would have been considered
Unthinkable in the tech poy era many
times a performer will simply stop the
Poise movement entirely to set up new
tricks or combos or even just to
Showcase how clean one's lines are Tech
POI embraced a variety of ways to change
the direction or plane of the poy but
stopping the movement to the PO entirely
and keeping it in suspension was almost
never done and unlike Tech the influence
of circus and manipulation has also
favored putting together all of these
tricks and combos into longer acts that
are intended for stage performance okay
so real talk why am I so focused on
placing a division between these two
artistic movements in the PO World well
first up I think that it's important to
honor artistic movements for their own
intentions rather than see them in the
context of other artistic movements
impressionism was seen as degenerate
when it first emerged in the salons of
Paris the older academ mic style was
seen as true art and yet the fact of the
matter was that impressionism was
conveying its own form of Truth it
simply had a different goal and a
different perspective on the world than
the academic style did likewise
manipulation as a style is succeeding on
its own terms it doesn't need to be
Techo to be accomplishing what it's
setting out to do do we have clean and
beautiful lines check do we have po
being used as a discrete object and its
relationship to the human body explored
in great detail check have many of the
more important Concepts and tricks in
juggling been successfully performed
with po check and I think Tech po also
succeeded but at very different goals
did it take a chaotic and random
assortment of Po tricks and come up with
ways to categorize them into something
easier to understand check did it guide
us to a diverse array of mathematically
beautiful POI patterns flowers and
hybrids that have now become standard
check did he give us tools for
understanding how po moved and what
other potential moves awaited for us out
there
check second understanding the context
for different artistic movements coming
and going can tell us a lot about our
broader culture and the impacts that it
has on Art manipulation seeks to
integrate techniques and ideas from the
juggling world into poy but that
wouldn't be possible without a highly
developed culture around numbers
juggling that social media and online
video helped to make possible it's a
style of poy that's ideally suited to
short vertically formatted videos that
are designed to show off a single trick
or sequence and give the audience
instant gratification and payoff it's a
style of poy that centers the prop
definitively in the unlit world as fire
spinning becomes more difficult to
engage in due to permitting restrictions
and the price of fuel going up having a
style of Po that not only works but
works better without fire is a great way
to adapt to changing times and it is an
excellent fit for people seeking Refuge
from an increasingly abstract unstable
world with something that is physical
tactile and immediate finally finally I
think it's important to recognize these
shifts in artistic movements because of
the ways that they can influence the
artistic movements that come after them
is it possible that Tech POI could have
a Resurgence in popularity you never
know I'd say that the Russian School of
Po spinning has been keeping many of the
stylistic conventions of techy alive for
the past decade if tech poy can be
overtaken by another artistic movement
it also stands to reason that this could
happen to manipulation too what will
come next personally I see some signs
that social media is likely to change
radically in the coming years Tik Tok
has dropped from being the most visited
site on the internet to not even being
in the top 10 this year how might it
change in how we communicate and share
affect the PO world we have generation
Alpha beginning to enter their teen
years now how has coming of age during
and after the coid pandemic impacted how
they interact with their hobbies and the
world around them will they be looking
to find a different relationship with
the prop than either Millennial Techo
artists or the Zoomer manipulation
artists placing people and art into
discret boxes is always one of those
exercises that carries with it potential
for both great rewards as well as great
risks at its best identifying movements
like this can help us gain Clarity and
appreciation for their philosophy and
intent but can also impose unnatural and
inappropriate boundaries on phenomena
that may or may not fall cleanly into
those boxes famously the media coined
the term grunge to describe a Cadre of
seattle-based bands that played loud
guitar-based Rock centered around
introspection alienation and societal
Decay and the bands hated the term they
felt like it was an inaccurate and
superficial simplification of their work
and relationships it could be that Techo
has just become a generic term like
modern or alternative rock terms that
are meaningless aside from signifying
that the radio station formats that host
them are playing Rock but not classic
rock Tech POI likewise might simply
signify an artist performing Advanced Po
in whatever specific form that happens
to take at a given time time but I think
the words that we use should have some
meaning and context otherwise why use
them in the first place I think words
can give power to a movement by naming
it I think that they can help us clarify
what we do and do not identify with when
we see a work of art and if nothing else
they can start a discussion that we can
learn a lot from but what do you think
do you think manipulation is a good
label for the style of Po that's been
dominant for the past decade do you
think it should all just be Tech poy and
if so what should we call the that was
dominant in the late 2000s drop me a
comment and let me know did you get
anything out of this video please leave
a like comment share and subscribe to
keep the conversation going and to help
my channel
[Music]
grow thank you so much for watching this
video it would not have been possible
without the wonderful support of my
patreon supporters in particular I want
to give a shout out to my flow patrons
who are listed on screen now if you're
interested in checking out more videos
I've done on PO and flow Arts culture
I'll go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist down in the description and if
you'd like to support the channel I will
leave a link to my patreon down in the
description as well make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
brand new video real soon take care now
peace